everyone happy Monday we're going to go
ahead and start off today by reviewing
the bake-off results from last week so
just as a refresher last week's bake-off
was on the task of sentiment analysis
yeah so it was the three class tasks
positive neutral and negative we were
evaluating on the Stanford sentiment
treebank
test set that had a total of 2,200
sentences um and we use the macro f1
score as the evaluation metric yeah so
basically like taking the accuracy on
every class and then averaging all of
those yeah so we had a pretty imbalance
test set with like 900 of the positive
and negative examples and then 400
neutral and in general the worst
performance was seen on the neutral
class which is kind of expected giving
this class imbalance so yeah here is a
histogram of the scores that you guys
submitted so yeah but highest score was
almost like 0.7 and the mode was around
0.5 0.55 and you can kind of see like
where you fall in comparison to our like
just basic you know grams plus softmax
baseline which is actually kind of like
above this peach here so that was pretty
interesting that you know basic you know
grams can get you so far
yeah and so we have the winners of the
bake-off Oh before that what's gonna
distinguish the high scores from the low
scores um so we kind of looked at the
like tokens that appeared in the
submissions for the top scores which we
kind of defined as like scores that are
about above 25/8 and as you can see it's
like you know mostly kind of a lot of
deep learning approaches and people who
leveraged bert representations yeah and
then in the low scores it's kind of a
mixed bag you see some of the like
baseline of feature functions that were
in the assignment originally as well as
like some glow
tokens so it's interesting to see like
how far Burt has surpassed you know like
approaches that are not even really
outdated but like you know things that
we were using just last year that were
like winning the bake-off are now you
know in this low score section so that's
really interesting yeah
now on to our first-place group so
congratulations to group thirteen
achieving score of point six nine two
using their balance dataset and
end-to-end Burt approach yeah so group
thirteen used some smart like data
process pre-processing first like
balancing the data supply over sampling
which is very smart because of the data
set imbalance and I mentioned before and
then actually like rejoining the
contractions in the data set and this is
kind of like an artifact of how Burt was
trained so it's interesting that like
you know this like you know undoing the
pre-processing essentially um actually
helped a little bit in terms of
performance and then they trained the
Burt model and to end basically like
fine-tuning Burt for the sentiment
classification task yeah so a good job
to that team now for our second-place
team group 51 um used a similar approach
of using Burt to create the future
representations and then using a neural
net classifier on top of that so
congratulations to group 51 as well they
achieved a score of 0.65 one you know
doing a similar thing of fine-tuning
Bert on SST and then running inference
to generate the features for each
sentence and then feeding that into our
torch or house fire and they also used
the strategy of kind of like up sampling
examples from the neutral class to do
better on that class and we also wanted
to point out some other interesting
approaches in addition to our top two
teams so we wanted to shout out group
nine which did super well actually
getting our like the same score as our
top team but unfortunate
we can't qualify to win the bake-off
because they actually used the sub-tree
labels but it's still a very interesting
approach so we wanted to point it out
this group actually formulated the task
as a sequence to sequence tasks using
like the strings containing the sentence
annotations and streets tree structure
as the input sequence and then the
sentiment label as an output sequence of
length 1 so that was pretty cool
basically the only group to think of
formulating the problem that way and
actually one of the only groups among
the top teams to not use Bert or Elmo
and then just using a two layer
bi-directional STM for a classification
and then we also want to just shout out
anyone who tried future engineering
unfortunately the feature engineering
didn't make it into any of like the top
scoring systems but that was interesting
to us on the teaching team because last
year's top two systems actually both
used hand-built like bag of words based
features with a simple logistic logistic
regression classifier although this year
a lot of the top teams relied on deep
learning it's kind of shows like shift
in the field yeah so these are the top
two teams from last year and these
scores aren't comparable to this year
because they were for the binary tasks
what we were doing the ternary tasks
this year but yeah our teaching team is
well represented here but in first place
last year
Jada's team used pre-processing with
just like removing punctuation and then
character Engram features of various
lengths as well as TF IDs and then just
logistic regression classifier and that
managed to get a really really good
score on this task so yeah it's
interesting to see like yeah you know
how what we were doing last year with
like manual on future engineering has
like kind of been totally replaced this
year by massive compute created
pre-trained Burtt representation and
second place um Lucy's team shout out to
Lucy also used somewhere like kind of
feature engineering approach
with like very very rich features you
know grams by grams negation words
leveraging a sentiment lexicon yeah so
that's like also a direction that liking
it could definitely go I'm sure to you
do the sentiment task maybe like in your
class project or something like that
yeah and I think that's about it anyone
have any questions about last week's
bake-off from the top two teams here I
wonder whether those are kind of
theoretically the same system because it
sounds like the first team used Byrd and
used a PI torch layer on top to fit a
classifier maybe a deep one and the
second-place team just used our
classifier as opposed to the one that
the virtue released so I wonder if it's
just a difference of like how they were
optimized or actually maybe there's a
there's a deeper difference that I'm
overlooking but they look very similar
yeah because they must be that team one
just didn't use torch shell and their
own classifier rather something that's
part of the birth of the per PI torch
code release yeah it means this group
just kind of like tweaked the final
layers of the Bert model like the
pre-existing like PI toward
implementation yeah see our deep
learning code on the internet you find
that in some file somewhere in the code
base someone has done some very careful
pre-processing presumably this is to
sort of get properly into the Bert
vocabulary or something yeah I was
curious about this actually today on the
first page you should like unprocess
your token so it looks more like broad
text
well thank you yeah and I've got my
slides and everything maybe this will be
my new solution so okay so thank you
bake-off stuff first I just wanted to
say that Amazon gave us enough codes so
that we can give $50 codes for AWS to
people who win the bake-off so the first
team got their codes and that winning
team there will get codes and we'll keep
that up it has to be just the top
scoring system numerically because we
don't have that many extras some some
more teams might get extra credit than
that but it is nice that we can reward
the very top teams other bake-off stuff
so I posted bake-off 3 on Piazza I think
it's straightforward it looks a lot like
the procedure for bake-off 1 in the
sense that you need to download some
data and then that you're pretty much
just just running code that you've
written
but of course post on Piazza if there
are any issues there I also wanted to
mention that there was a PI torch and
numpy tutorial on Friday and the team
produced great notebooks for that I
think it's especially
and so I posted those at the homepage at
the top on the first day it's a bit
revisionist but it's kind of like
introduction to Jupiter notebooks and
now you have the stuff for numpy and pi
torch and I think the timing of that is
really nice because you guys might be
thinking about projects you want to do
and for your projects you might want to
dive into the PI torch a little bit and
then the final thing I want to do here
before I dive into nli is just kind of
introduce homework four and the bake-off
and the reason I want to do that first
is work it's a kind of reversal and
we're going to talk we're going to talk
about natural anguish inference all week
this week and the bake-off is about
natural language inference but because
the really good and ally datasets are
enormous I didn't want you to have to do
that for a bake-off because it would
consume a lot of time and a lot of
resources so instead for homework four
and bake-off four we're gonna do just a
word level and tailmon task and this is
kind of nice because it's like a
microcosm of the whole nli problem it
just removes a lot of the overhead from
processing large data sets and it's kind
of nicely constrained in some
interesting ways so let me just start by
introducing it because they're kind of
two or three intellectual things that I
think are worth calling out so the first
the framing throughout this problem set
the training instances are going to be
pairs like hippo and mammal just words
people have actually developed labeled
data sets that just tell you for these
at the word level whether the first
entails the second that's basically the
task so it's a binary task with
vocabulary like this basically because
it's constrained to just words you have
to make just a few decisions here so
first kind of like in bake-off one you
need to decide how you're gonna
represent the pair of those words so
hippo and mammal are just items in your
vocabulary but you can look them up in
some embedding space first of all and
you can decide what embedding space and
it can be any embedding space I guess
the smart move based on past bake-offs
is to use something like Bert or Elmo
sorry my phone is hardwired to stop to
shut off very quickly
try to avoid that so you'll want to look
up hippo and mammal in an embedding
space you can also decide how you're
going to represent them right so I think
like what I've suggested here is
concatenation but you could do something
else if you wanted difference or
multiplication or some whatever you
wanted to do so
so embedding and then representation and
then from there you're gonna want to fit
some kind of model right so the simplest
thing would be to fit like a basic
classifier but you could have also a
very deep network in there right lots of
hidden representations and I'm gonna
leave it entirely up to you what you
want to do there I fit a baseline that's
kind of a shallow deep learning model
but you can do really whatever you want
and that's the bake-off that make sense
and you can see that this is a microcosm
of the whole nli problem because after
all for nli it's just that hippo and
mammal can both be complete sentences
are very complicated noun phrases but in
the end also we have three labels as
you'll see for our output space but
fundamentally this is the same kind of
problem it just means that you can
iterate much more quickly because the
data sets are smaller and there's less
to process there's one other subtlety
that I want to point out here so you
have a data set that comes with a
notebook it's already in your data
folder and there are two conditions for
it I've called the first one edge
disjoint and that just means that the
pairs on training and testing you're
trained and dev but also tests which
I'll release as part of the make off the
at the edge level things are disjoint
what that means is that you could see a
lot of the same vocabulary at train and
test time right so like hippo and mammal
if you saw them in training you won't
see exactly that pair but you might have
seen hippo paired with other words and
mammal paired with other words that's a
kind of standard formulation of this
problem but it's kind of easy to gain in
the sense that you know the systems that
result from this often look very good in
terms of performance but you might doubt
whether they have actually learned to
generalize because it could be that
they've just kind of learned to
triangulate within the space that
they're in
do pretty well on the test set and you
can kind of see that because some
baselines which I'm going to tell you
about later tend to be very high for
this problem like if I give you only the
second word what we'll call only the
hypothesis maybe you get like 80% so I
are not going to focus on that task
instead we're gonna focus on this
condition that I've called word disjoint
and what that means is that for train
and dev and also for test the
vocabularies are disjoint so that means
if you saw hippo and mammal and training
you will not see either of those words
at test time and it entails therefore
that you won't see that you'd haven't
seen those edges before right so this is
a strictly harder problem that is really
testing your networks ability not only
to do well at words at scene but also to
generalize from that into other parts of
the lexicon yeah you mentioned slightly
above that one of the possibilities for
the embedding is just a random embedding
there that work with we're just trying
to get a random embedding it certainly
does not yes your intuition is exactly
right if you have a random initial
embedding then you will produce random
results on the knot on the edge disjoint
you could do really well on edge
disjoint but onward disjoint you will
flounder and what that means is that you
need to initialize with a rich space and
you'll see in the baselines that I've
put down here that I did glove but kind
of the striking and interesting thing
about this is that initializing with
glove where I assume with Bert and Elmo
really gives you a lot of traction on
this problem even on the M word disjoint
condition so I've walked through just to
show you in a bit more detail in this
notebook what these two datasets are
like and I've kind of built up this
argument here for why we might want to
use the word disjoint condition I also
set a baseline which uses these glove
vectors here so that as the kind of
fundamental representation of the words
you just do a glove lookup in a way that
you guys have done on earlier problems
and for my baseline combination function
for the two words I just used
concatenation and then for the
a fire as I said before I use this torch
shallow neural classifier from the
course repo 50 dimensional hidden
representations a modest number of
iterations and as you guys are probably
accustomed to at this point we have this
kind of little experiment wrapper that
should make it pretty easy for you to
run experiments so you know model is
your the model that you want to test it
could be anything
glove vac and vet concatenate those are
really the three points that you'll want
variation on and you'll probably just
want to use train and dev therefore your
your development phase so for my
baseline I got macro everage point six
nine which is pretty good but obviously
the goal for you in doing the homework
and the bake-off is to see how much you
can build off of that baseline with a
richer network or more interesting
representations or more in different
ways to combine the two word vectors to
form your input representation that
making sense so far any questions
comments concerns it should be a fun one
because you can really develop models
fast so you should be able to try a lot
of different things this is sort of
anticipating stuff that I want to
discuss for you but let me just walk
through the rationale for the homework
so the first one is called hypothesis
only baseline as you'll see as we go
through the material people discovered a
few years ago that you could actually do
really well on many nli datasets if you
threw out the first part so in my hippo
mammal pair just throw out hippo and
make your classification purely on the
basis of the word mammal and I want to
discuss that with you because I think
it's kind of an interesting thing that
mixes maybe some artifacts in these data
sets but also a pretty deep fact about
how the lexicon is organized and what it
means to be in an entitlement
relationship I mean if you think about
that it's not surprising that mammal
would be more likely to occur on the
right and an entailment pair than the
left because of its generality oh and
actually this fact about hypothesis only
baselines was discovered by a student in
this class which i think is really cool
for his as far as I know the first
person to observe this for the SN Li
data set which is a big
entailment data set was a project in
this course in 2015 and then
subsequently a number of other groups
discovered it and quantified it so what
we're asking you to do here is to just
see how strong the hypothesis only
baseline is for this data set and what
we're trying to signal there is that
given these for this prior work if you
tackle an n Li problem then basically
you should fit a hypothesis only
baseline because random is not your
baseline at all it's actually this one
so it asked you to do that that's pretty
straightforward and then it just asks
you in the spirit of thinking freely
about this to explore an alternative
representation to concatenation so that
you might think about some interesting
kind of a priori ways that you might
combine the two representations
maybe difference is interesting for an
entailment space or multiplication or
something like that and then this is
where that PI torch tutorial might come
in I'm going to ask you to do a little
bit of work kind of sub classing one of
our PI torch classes and adding
essentially another layer and a drop out
layer drop out as a form of
regularization that's very easy to
implement in pi torch I've kind of
presented the mathematical details here
but I think you'll find that the
important thing is to just use the PI
torch documentation to figure out how to
add into your sequential model a drop
out layer and then you'll be off and
running and again the spirit of this is
to get you thinking about how
regularization for your networks might
be a powerful technique to avoid
overfitting and stuff like that and I've
kind of started you and given you some
instructions and we're happy to talk
with you about the best strategy for
this kind of coding on Piazza and then
finally as usually you do your original
system we'll see what happens
I don't think I have to impose any rules
on this you can download vectors from
the internet you can download code as
long as you do as you do something
original with it and the reason I can
say that is because the bake-off will be
conducted on a held out data set that I
have not given you so you can do all the
development you want on the data we've
provided just don't over fit too much
because then you'll get hit at test time
in the bake-off
make sense
any questions about that before we dive
into the regular material so that was a
small glimpse of the problem that you'll
be exploring but what we're going to
focus on this week is the problem in its
fullness this problem of natural
language inference I think this is a
wonderful problem because I think it
gets at something really deep about what
we're trying to do in NLU and also there
is an abundance of really interesting
datasets at this point because the field
has kind of triangulated on an
interesting methodology for collecting
these datasets and people have found
that it's pretty easy to crowdsource
good ones I mean there are some issues
that we'll discuss but by and large this
has kind of been productionize dand so
you have multiple datasets that are in
the same format making it very easy to
experiment so I don't encourage having a
default project for this course because
I think it's interesting for you guys to
get creative but if there were a default
project I would certainly say it should
be something with nli because it tests
lots of the concepts that we've
introduced there's a really wide space
of models that you can explore and these
datasets are so good I also want to say
that there are many special connections
to this course for nli so it used to be
called RTE until bill came along for his
thesis he started calling it natural
language inference and builded lots of
seminal work in the space kind of
exploring how you might apply natural
logic which has a very rich algebra of
inferential relationships to NLP tasks
in this space and so he'd like bill as
part of the resurgence of interest in
this problem and then Sam Bowman was a
student in this course and was also my
student and I think the full history of
this is that Richard so sure came and
gave a lecture on you know tree
structured networks for sentiment
analysis it was about the time that we
were developing the Stanford sentiment
tree Bank and Sam was captivated I think
Sam was not focused on NLU at the time
for his research but that was a kind of
important moment for him and he wanted
to work on nli because I think he
admired bill's work and and he liked
thinking like a cement assist
but there weren't really good datasets
he felt kind of stuck by the ones that
were available and he just did the
really admirable and ambitious thing of
saying let's collect a massive data set
for nli so that we can test these new
deep learning models because one one
sticking point at that point was that
the available datasets were kind of too
small to really test these deep learning
approaches so Sam developed SN Li and
the rest is history the the task has
been renamed nobody says RTE anymore and
we have all these interesting datasets
and Sam has been a real powerhouse in
terms of developing new ones so he's
responsible for both SN Li and multi and
Li which is the two datasets that we're
going to concentrate on and then just
while I'm in this vein I want to mention
also that both yes they're both working
hard on n Li problems right now kind of
using it to stress test neural systems
to see what they're actually learning
about semantics using them as a testbed
for interesting new neural models that
he's developing with some researchers at
IBM so there are lots of us on the
teaching team all are interested in
talking with you about n Li here's my
overview um I'm gonna give you a bit of
background on the problem and I'm gonna
introduce these two datasets SN Li and
multi in Li and then we're gonna do the
kind of standard narrative for this
course I'm going to show you some
hand-built feature functions which I
think are really good and interesting
baselines for the problem and having
done that then I'm going to show you
that we have in the course repo a nice
framework for doing experiments on all
these kind of SN Li style datasets from
there we're going to start to look at
deep learning models and n Li is
interesting as compared to sentiment
because basically you have two texts to
work with the premise and the hypothesis
and that opens up lots of interesting
avenues for doing modeling because you
can think about how to model the premise
and hypotheses separately and how to
relate them and then finally how to fit
a classifier so we'll look at sentence
encoding models chained models those are
kind of the main classes and then as an
orthogonal development I'm going to show
you some stuff on attention which has
risen to prominence recently I think an
ally and also machine translation were
kind of motivating problems for
attention in NLU so we'll talk about
those kind of things and how you might
add them to your systems to do even
better and then finally we'll talk about
error analysis these things will
probably come on Wednesday we'll see how
things go but I think again because of
nli is very rich grounding in
linguistics you have some very
interesting avenues for thinking about
error analysis and how it might relate
to linguistic patterns and logical
patterns and stuff like that so that's
our full plot as usual we have a lot of
material so NL IGI is your main module
both for the homework and if you want to
work with these larger data sets and
then there are two notebooks so the task
and data one introduces SN Li and multi
and Li and shows you the code that we
have for working with them and then the
second notebook is a whole lot of
modeling code to kind of get you started
if you want to pursue this task we've
gone over homework 4 and bake-off 4 and
then I'll just mention that the core
readings in my mind we posted a few more
but I would say the core readings are
Boman at all 2015 that introduced SN Li
and set up some initial baselines and
then this Rock techel at all that's a
seminal paper in terms of introducing
attention word by word attention into
the n Li problem and showing that it
could lead to big gains and then I also
recommend some exodia readings so the
Goldberg 2015 is that primer on deep
learning models that I also recommended
in the last unit so that's kind of
separate then for n Li in particular
dogging at all is a very important
foundational paper that more or less
introduced the task of RTE and then
McCartney and Manning that's a nice
presentation of this natural logic
approach that Bill developed and then
Williams at all is the paper that
introduced multi and Alli and that's
another good resource for you in terms
of baselines and in terms of
understanding what's in that dataset
these are typical and Li examples I
picked them a little bit strategically
just to give you a sense for the kind of
variation that we see so the top one
there you would say that turtle and
linguist
predict each other that would be the
label for that pair in our homework we
just have yes/no on entailment but in
the data sets that we'll focus on today
and on Wednesday
you have 3-way labels contradiction and
tailmon and neutral and so we would say
that turtle and linguist contradict each
other there's already some complexity
there because you can easily imagine a
possible world in which some turtles
have are qualified as linguists right
that's you can kind of already see that
we're not going to be dealing with a
notion of logical contradiction but
rather something closer to common sense
inference based on world knowledge a
turtle danced and a turtle moved that
actually might be closer to just being a
true entailment fact because of the
lexical relationship between dance and
move the only assumption you need to
bring in there is that these two turtles
are the same turtle and that's actually
a touchy point when you get to
naturalistic data and I'm gonna return
to it but kind of what we're doing now
is making some assumptions about event
or entity coreference
across the premise and hypothesis and in
that case dance and tales move and so we
get entailment yeah so you're assuming
that I guess to to be careful about it
I'm not assuming that a turtle dance but
rather if a turtle danced then the
turtle moved I think the flavor is much
more like that but again with some
qualifications because this is
naturalistic data as you can see it's
actually based on image captions and so
there is some commitment to the premises
being realistic I guess I just like
turtles and that's why I picked it right
like because you're interpreting diet
with him like yeah yeah fair enough then
you would be the probably the outlier
and the Tator
if you were asked to do the annotation
but you have a defensible point the
logician in me wants to say you know
that's certainly not a contradiction the
first one and that the second one is not
necessarily in entailment unless I have
proper existential closure of the two
variables across the premise and
hypothesis yeah this is the kind of
thing you have to get used to I would
say it's not so much checking for common
sense knowledge as acknowledging that
this is pervasive in this task and that
you might the way you might even think
about the nli problem is as you know one
that requires an understanding of common
sense reasoning and kind of world
knowledge and that that's fueling the
system doing well at these problems but
it's it's really difficult because a
turtle disk then that implies that at
least some tails move and so eternal
like if any old turtle dance then there
is some turtle that moved yeah that's
fair yeah every reptile danced a turtle
ate those would be neutral again like
that that's sort of a logical fact I
think some turtles walk no turtles move
those contradict each other and this is
a classic example from bill's thesis
James Byron Dean refused to move without
blue jeans and tails James Dean didn't
dance without pants
I guess bill is highlighting not only
the kind of linguistic complexity of
this reasoning task because it might
take you a minute to see that those are
in an attainment relationship but also
that as part of this you might have to
solve some stuff like figuring out that
James Byron Dean and James Dean are the
same person and for that you might need
a lot of world knowledge of a particular
kind but I think that those follow more
or less logically we don't need much
common sense reasoning there that will
be very different for the
so on Mitsubishi motor corpse new
vehicle sales in the US fail 40 fell 46%
in June and Mitsubishi sales rose 46%
oh no that one's straightforward that's
just a contradiction fall and rise I
guess we have to make some assumptions
about the domain of these claims and
I'll return to that but by and large
those seem like they contradict each
other
this next one definitely involves common
sense reasoning Acme corporation
reported that its CEO resigned and tails
Acme CEO resigned
it certainly doesn't because companies
can report anything they want and
sometimes they report false things and
so strictly speaking if we were cement
Isis we would say that this report has
no entailments with respect to the
complement their Acme CEO resigned but
again it's a kind of common sense thing
given that we know that this corporation
is likely a reliable source about this
kind of information then we might infer
entailment or annotators might be
encouraged to infer entailment fine line
here because to assume the same person
because take the example of like george
w bush george it's done something if you
called one Gorge bush and the other you
had to specify by point yeah
maybe in that so in the back of your
mind you should be thinking that there's
a practical side of this which is that
we want systems that could just read
through newspaper text for example and
figure out what the entailments are or
what the logical relationships are and
in that case this isn't a problem we can
ignore rather we need systems that are
sensitive to that level of distinction
and that know how many George Bush's
there are at some implicit level and
that can also resolve these to the same
entity but the uncertainty that you guys
are feeling this is wonderful you sound
like linguists this is the the linguist
reaction to this problem is usually none
of these things have any of these
logical relationships it's all neutral
because I can think of edge cases where
it falls apart and I have to just rotate
to retreat to the idea that we're kind
of trying to get a hold of what you as a
reader would infer from these texts or
and for from
pairs of sentences is there a way to
rephrase the task so that it can detect
the ambiguity or it sort of reported or
really would and if so how would you go
about doing sort of make finer
distinctions between logical entailment
and common-sense reasoning and abduction
and all these other notions that are in
play here I think yeah here so this kind
of summarizes this and I I would refer
you to this trio of articles this is a
kind of back and forth these are all
Stanford people or at one time they were
all stand for people kind of having a
debate about how much non logical
reasoning we should allow to creep into
this problem and so I think I won't
resolve it but it's an interesting
discussion I do think though that the
top of this kind of summarizes the view
that I'm trying to convey which is does
the premise justify an inference to the
hypothesis given some common sense
assumptions about the world and the
speaker and our intentions and so forth
yeah that's the heart of it and then the
other aspects of this problem is that
there's been a focus on kind of local
inference or just premise and hypothesis
and there's a lot of emphasis on
capturing variability in these
expressions like different ways that you
might refer to people different ways
that the same concept might be
articulated and so forth and so on I do
think that what happens if you try to be
strict about this and say that you're
going to look only at logical entailment
is that the problem gets kind of small
and limited it's basically just like
really reliable lexical relationships
and then even then the linguist come in
and say wait a second word since
ambiguities are causing me even to doubt
this thing that you thought was a solid
entailment then it all kind of falls
apart and that's why that's the story I
tell myself about why it actually makes
sense to think about this as a common
sense reasoning task as much as I might
like logical inference this is kind of
nice this is from that important paper
by Ito doggin and colleagues that
introduced RTE what we now call nli and
I'll just read this it seems that major
inferences as needed by multiple
applications can indeed be cast in terms
of textual entailment consequently we
hypothesize that texture
tailmon recognition is a suitable
generic task for evaluating and
comparing applied semantic inference
models eventually such efforts can
promote the development of entailment
recognition engines which may provide
useful generic modules across
applications I think it's a nice
articulation of a dream for nli as a
task the idea would be if we can get our
systems to be really good at this kind
of basic but pervasive logical reasoning
then the capabilities they have would
apply in lots of domains and that
certainly resonates with me as a cement
assist because I kind of think of
entailment and contradiction as being
really central to how we think about
language how we reason with it how we
use it and so forth yeah I mean you're
speaking in vague language right you're
keying into his framing which is to say
like you know challenging problems in
nli maybe they turn on misunderstanding
or reformulations we can actually reduce
them into an nli task and that'd be
wonderful because if we could then the
models I'm showing you today would have
a lot more applicability so I'm not sure
precisely what you mean but I'm really
open-minded about this and I've actually
tried to do some of this here this is
actually taken from IDO doggins article
you know paraphrase detection is a well
known task you could think of that as
just the task of saying is the text and
its purported paraphrase equal in some
extended sense of common-sense reasoning
or summarization would say does the
input text entail the summary which
would be like saying we want at least as
a constraint on summarization that the
result is somewhat more general than the
input information retrieval could go in
the reverse direction you could you
could formulate that as saying that you
would like essentially to return
documents that entail the query in the
extended sense of nli and then question
answering is one that you can basically
reduce to saying that you want the
answer to entail the
if you are willing to massage the
question into a declarative form a
little bit so for example if you were
willing to replace in English all the WH
words within definites so that who left
became someone left then you have a
straightforward nli task and you're
really saying you would like an answer
like sandy left to entail someone left
and you would call that your notion of
answer hood and I think there are other
tasks out there that you could try to
reduce to the same form and that's the
inspiring idea that we've really gone
kind of down to the metal here in terms
of understanding reasoning and language
which is applicable to lots of different
areas again by way of background this is
sort of interesting this is a landscape
of different approaches that people have
taken to the nli problem so up here I
have logic and theorem proving those are
kind of the earliest approaches inspired
by logic in linguistics and I've put
them very high on the depth of
representations access because of course
they give you very high fidelity
pictures of the data but along the
x-axis I have
effectiveness which is kind of like if
you give me a whole lot of data does
this model do good and interesting
things with it in a comprehensive way
and the main limitation of logic and
theorem proving systems is because they
tend to be handcrafted they're high on
the y-axis but low on the x-axis build
developed this natural logic approach
which is kind of intermediate so it was
very rich logically but because the
logic is defined over natural language
utterances you have a lot of power to
apply it to larger data sets and so it
kind of moved us to the right along the
x-axis with some sacrifice in terms of
the depth of representations but still
very rich below that I put semantic
graphs which was another kind of
handcrafted approach that depended a lot
on very high fidelity alignments between
the premise and hypothesis again getting
more effective with some sacrifices in
terms of interpret ability and so forth
and then over here at the top I have
clever hand-built features kind of as
exemplified in this production system
called the excitment open platform which
is a good kind of classical system for
solving
the nli problem and then down just below
it I put Engram variations we're going
to look at some of those today so by
that point you're very effective those
models can be very powerful but very low
in terms of them offering a deep
understanding of the nli problem
basically you just have a lot of
superficial associations and then
something interesting has happened so I
put deep learning 2015 there because in
2015 when we really introduced this task
into the course proper the deep learning
models were not really a slam-dunk this
was kind of before or just at the time
SNL I was being introduced and by and
large those systems were being beaten by
handcrafted ones I do think it's safe to
say that by now in 2019 deep learning
models have overtaken the hand-built
ones to the point where even for the
little experiments that you see in my
notebooks and so forth it's very easy
for you to beat a very strong
handcrafted features baseline using some
deep learning techniques and then I
mentioned that there are a lot of data
sets here's a whole bunch of them so the
fracas textual inference test suite is
interesting historically because that is
an attempt to have a data set where
basically you have been confined at
least for the parts that we're talking
about to logical inference problems so
it's small but I think still really
interesting as a kind of test set if you
want to distress test your system for
example and then pre SNL I there were a
few data sets like SEM eval 2013 to
seven about 2014 that was the sick data
set which I actually distributed as part
of the data set for the course because
Sam Bowman put it into the SN Li format
so it's there if you want to play around
with it but again it's kind of small and
had some idiosyncrasies and that was
before SNL I and then after s noi you
have a flourishing of data sets that are
in the same mould so med nli is for
medical stuff very challenging problem
very rich vocabulary X and Li is
multilingual and Li data sets that have
been derived from ulta noi by a group of
facebook diverse natural language
inference collection is again a really
large scale
very diverse set of problems from a
group at Hopkins Scytale is SNL I like
but it's derived from science questions
and multiple-choice questions and also
web text so that's also really
challenging and then I put - just to
kind of get you thinking about this in
the mode of either doggins so like the
factoid question answer corpus can be
thought of as a kind of nli problem if
you want to put it into that mold or the
pen paraphrase database is just a simple
version of nli where you're trying to
get just one relationship and then
really interesting this is a newer
development the glue benchmark was
released by Sam Bowman and his group and
what they did is it's a whole bunch of
nli tasks I think five of them and then
a whole bunch of other tasks that aren't
strictly nli problems but are meant to
kind of test the doggone assumption that
if you have a good n li system then
those representations will transfer to
other tasks and a lot of people have
been working with that day there's a lot
of progress right now on the glue
benchmark so for a very ambitious final
project you could tackle that in whole
or in part I think I'll skip over this
these are some different label sets that
have been explored over the years for
better or worse we've kind of
consolidated on this three-way one
because of SN Li but before that there
were four-way versions and simpler
two-way versions like you'll explore in
the homework I mentioned this before
because this is relevant for the
homework I have you testing this
hypothesis yeah so landed kesselmann in
this prod in this course for his final
project observed the strength of
hypothesis only baselines and it's been
substantiated by a bunch of other groups
including one by Sam Bowman it's
interesting to ask why this holds so why
would it be why could you get any
traction at all if you were just shown
the hypothesis and a premise hypothesis
pair initially that sounds very worrying
right because it sounds like there's
something deeply problematic about the
data that would allow you to leave off
so much of your example and still do
well I think it is something to worry
about but I'm not myself so worried
because I think this has a principled
explanation that is more or less
grounded in the problem itself I've
have summarized that in these three
statements here so specific claims are
likely to be premises in entailment
cases that's really easy for me to
imagine if I think of the word net
hierarchy so we're net is basically a
huge hierarchy of entailment relations
for nouns the things that are at the
bottom of those height that hierarchy
are very specific things like puppy and
kitten and they entail almost everything
else else in the hierarchy on up to
object so if I had if you show me just
the word puppy or kitten I have a very
good guess about whether it's in the
premise or the hypothesis conversely if
you show me something very general like
mammal or object or dog then it's very
likely to be on the right in that pair
just because if I drew another word from
the vocabulary it's unlikely to be above
it because so few words are and then
this extends also to contradiction so I
think that specific things are more
likely to lead to contradiction by the
kind of rules of the SN Li game because
we make some assumptions about event
coreference and so forth and if you've
described something very specific in the
in the in these terms it probably
excludes most other claims and so again
very specific things likely to lead you
to contradiction on either side so I
think it's the result of these three
observations that is driving a lot of
the strength of hypothesis only
baselines now if you believe that
argument it means that this isn't really
something we're going to be able to
naturally factor out because this fact
about the entailment hierarchy is
something that we want our systems to
learn it's a it's an important semantic
fact and if you decided for example that
you would get rid of it by balancing
your data set so that every word had
equal likelihood of appearing as a
premise or hypothesis you could weaken
the hypothesis on the baseline but it's
not so clear to me that the resulting
systems would be solving the problem as
we encounter it in the world and for
that reason my response to this is just
to say let's always have in the top of
our results table a hypothesis only
baseline so that we know the starting
point for our task
that make sense anyone want to push back
on that yeah he does a premise only
baseline do anything it's on your
Explorer if you believe my
generalizations it ought to be better
than random because I think there is
information in just that what that part
but I haven't explored it too much my
code should make it really easy to
explore okay this is good timing let's
dive into what these datasets are like
so we're gonna look at SN Li and multi
and a lie which are a kind of common
mold for datasets like this at this
point so here's a quick summary it was
released by Bowman at all 2015 all of
the premises are image captions from the
Flickr 30k data set and that's really
important to keep in mind because image
captions are kind of unusual bits of
language and it also means that all of
these things at some level for people
who produce them were grounded in a
specific image and I think that has
shaped the data the hypotheses were all
written by crowd workers so this was a
very large crowdsourcing task because
this has over 500,000 examples and all
of those hypotheses were written by
people and then parts of the data set
were evaluated by other humans right I
should note that some of the sentences
reflect stereotypes this is a nice paper
from a Hopkins group again just pointing
out that as you might expect people who
are doing lots of crowd work kind of
relied on some shortcuts to producing
contradiction and entailment pairs and a
byproduct of that is that they end up
relying on problematic stereotypes so
this is something we would like to
eliminate from these datasets because we
don't want to perpetuate these problems
but for now I can just say that you
should be aware of this yeah so about
550 training examples 10k dev and 10k
tests I've given some information of
like the mean length of the examples the
types of clauses so they're not all
sentences some of them are noun phrases
it's got a fairly large vocabulary
almost 40,000 words and then it has
a smaller subset of about 60,000
examples that were validated by for
additional annotators if you want
increased confidence that the label is
correct and that went rather well there
was a very high level of agreement for
the labels and then finally down here
there's a leaderboard which has a truly
overwhelming number of papers on it now
it's kind of hard to digest and I think
we're past the day where you would just
like hope that you were the highest row
I would think about it somewhere more
flexibly so say I'm already divided it
into a few different model classes and
you could think about where you want to
slot in and then another distinction
that has emerged is just whether or not
your model is an ensemble I would say
that for SNL I in particular we've
entered a phase where ensemble models
are just doing best and that's an
interesting game if you want to just
pursue raw performance but it's a kind
of different thing you're doing on in
the modeling sense than picking a single
model that you think reflects an
intuition about the data or the problem
itself and pursuing it as far as you can
so think in a nuanced way about how
you're doing with your system with
respect to the leaderboard this is a
screen shot of the crowd sourcing
methods that were used it's kind of
small it's here just as documentation
obviously for a crowd workers we
couldn't just tell them hey construct a
sentence that entails the premise or
contradicts the premise because that's a
kind of specialized logical notion so I
think we found a way of framing it so
that it was pretty clear what we were
after but more naturalistic but if you
want to do a deep dive on what the data
actually mean this is important
information because this is the starting
point for how the examples were
constructed then here are some actual
examples these are the ones that are
given in the paper a man inspects the
uniform of a figure in some East Asian
country so remember that was the caption
of an image and then the contradiction
pair that the worker came up with was
I'm the man is sleeping and in a
subsequent validation phase all five
people agreed that that was a
contradiction label
I think these are pretty straightforward
you can kind of see that it looks anyway
like contradiction is very consistent
and there's more nuance especially
around what the neutral categories mean
I think that's borne out in the data
here are cases that I picked again just
to reintroduce this idea that it's not
so obvious how we're defining this so
these aren't actual examples from the
corpus but I think they abide by the
standards that were adopted so here's
the idea a boat sank in the Pacific
Ocean and a boat sank in the Atlantic
Ocean would be labeled this
contradiction of course those two things
could happen together so there's no
logical sense in which these are
contradictory but if we assume that what
we're doing is talking about a single
image like an you know that from the
image Flickr 30k data set then it's
likely that these contradict each other
that only one of them could possibly be
true and that's the sense in which this
is a contradiction relation and here's a
more extreme case that Sam came up with
so Ruth Bader Ginsburg was appointed at
the Supreme Court and I had a sandwich
for lunch today by this logic you would
say that those were contradictory again
not because they couldn't both be true
then maybe they are both true of you or
of me but rather that they couldn't be
describing the same event in some sense
does that make sense this tricky stuff I
mean more more or less at mercy at the
mercy of the data that we have but all
this is worth keeping in mind okay and
then the other data said I wanted to
introduce as multi-and a lie
released by Williams at all in 2018 it's
very similar in terms of its design with
some added nuance so first the training
set is drawn from a bunch of different
genres fiction government reports the
slate website the switch word corpus and
some travel guides and then went for the
dev set you have one condition where you
test on those same genres and another
where you where you test on some
completely different genres and those
are the 9/11 report
face to face which is some narratives
fundraising letters nonfiction and
articles about linguistics
and that's a really cool idea because
you might think that that's a way again
of stress testing your system of forcing
it to go outside of its training
experiences again it's very large it has
the same kind of an additional
annotations for validation and then the
one twist here is that I think to avoid
kind of a lot of hill climbing on the
test set the test set is released only
as a kegel competition to kind of reduce
the number of times that people can
evaluate on it and you can check out the
project page I think it links to a
leaderboard and some other information
if captions for the images premise is
like a man kicks a ball and like a man
is watching the game or something so
it's what they're both happening in the
same photo that's a great question so
basically like how comprehensive can we
count on the captions being I think you
can't count on anything I think image
captions are strange things that reflect
what humans regard as salient and so
they have their own interesting biases
and there have been some attempts like
here at Stanford with a visual genome
project to do image captioning of a sort
that's not so naturalistic to really
comprehensively label what's in the
images but that's not what was done for
image flickr 30k it's much more
naturalistic and so you're starting in
an interesting social and linguistic
space and then building on top of it in
an unusual direction that's the long and
short of it I've always thought though
that there's an opportunity here which
is that you might leverage the actual
images this has been done and frequently
or not at all but you can imagine that
you solved the problem by reasoning not
only about the premise the image caption
but also about an representation of the
image itself sorry about the phone doing
that
here's another really interesting thing
about the multi nli data set so Sam in
the group they released with the data
set a bunch of annotations for
properties of the individual examples so
for example they just labeled some as
being active passive pairs in the
premise and hypothesis and that's really
interesting because you expect that to
be kind of meaning preserving but it's
an open question whether your system can
be sensitive to that kind of
transformation or also categories like
whether there's a belief predicate like
believe or claim or say whether there's
conditionals whether coreference is
crucial because many systems just ignore
kind of like the pronouns but entailment
can often hinge on the nature of those
co-reference old relationships is it a
long sentence does it contain modal's
and negation could these two things be
called paraphrases what's the are there
quantifiers in the sentence these are
kind of quantifying the semantic
difficulty of the examples and this is
really nice you'll see this later when
we do air analysis you can use these
categories for a kind of out-of-the-box
error analysis you can ask for a bunch
of different systems which of these
categories are they doing well on and
where are they failing and that's often
very illuminating okay and just to round
this out just so you know about it this
is also in those notebooks here are some
code for dealing with these data sets
you have basically SNL I train reader
SNL I dev reader multi NL I train reader
and then you have the two dev readers
matched and mismatched and so those
should be good like easy ways for you to
interact with the data and feed it into
machine learning systems I think the
only thing you have to get used to is
they yield what are called example
objects you can see that happening I
guess here and that's because the
underlying data has not only the strings
and the relationship but also if it was
multiplied annotated all the decisions
the annotators made and also binary and
non binary parses of the examples which
are automatic parses that come from
Stanford's coronel P package but
you know they're good parses
by-and-large it worked well and that
gives you access to very rich tree
structures if you want to make use of
them and so that's a bit of a glimpse of
how you deal with those example objects
here's another example I know it's small
but it's there for you to download and
check out if you like and then here's a
bit of additional code that just shows
you the interface that we've provided
for dealing with the annotated subset so
that there are no obstacles to you
making use of it because I think it's
really exciting to stress test your
system by looking at how it does on
different classes of problem and they've
made that very easy for us excellent any
questions about those datasets at any
level before we started dive into the
modeling parts of this will kind of
embark on our familiar plot then so the
first thing that we'll do is look at
some hand-built feature functions and
some kind of classical linear models and
then we'll move into deep learning what
I've done here is defined just two very
simple baselines well that's nice I made
that bigger that you see a lot in the
literature the first is what I've called
word overlap Phi and it's just creating
a feature for every pair every word that
occurs both in the premise and the
hypothesis so that gives you pretty
sparse models and they're pretty small
because you're really looking at only
the overlapping words you can contrast
that with word cross-product and what
that does is create a feature for every
pair of words that occurs in the premise
and the hypothesis so you know the full
cross-product in the sense of you think
about them as two sets of words you look
at every pair that you can draw from
that pair of sets and that leads to
really enormous feature spaces I think
that if you fit a model with this
feature function on all of SN Li the
training data you end up with well over
a million and a half features so very
high-dimensional very sparse feature
space here's a way of looking at that so
like if I have Toby as a dog
and toby is a big dog then the word
overlap thing just keeps track of toby
dog is and uh and it drops out big
whereas the word Oh word cross-product
thing creates this enormous list of all
the pairs that I can form from those two
sets of words with their counts so much
much bigger those are kind of baseline
things here's something else a whole
class of features that you might think
about that could come from word Nets so
as I said before word net is a kind of
very high fidelity handcrafted resource
full of information about word level
relationships in particular entailment
relationships and some contradiction
information that is in the form of
antonyms and what I've done here is just
give you a little bit of code that shows
you how you might create feature
functions relying on the word net
hierarchy so as a quick example if I
just look up puppy I get all it's in
sets and they're like dog pup and young
person so you can see that the sense of
the word puppy is kind of ambiguous and
word net is capturing that if you go for
just the first of those CIN sets then
you get a kind of more conservative
perspective because the first sense I
think is the most frequent according to
their data and so from that and actually
there's lots of methods you could use
hypernym HIPPA NIM and so forth here's a
little example of how to create a word
net feature and I've done it for Hyper
names and HIPPA names and I'll just show
you an example so again if I have the
puppy moved and the dog danced then
hypernym features would give me a
feature for puppy and dog and hip and in
features would give me moved and danced
and you could do it with this code here
you could do this for lots of other word
net relationships and I think carve-out
pretty interesting subspaces of like
lexical and tailmon and contradiction
and so forth and here are some other
ideas so you can do lots more stuff with
word net you could also think about some
edit distance features between
the premise and hypothesis maybe at the
word level I showed you word overlap but
maybe it's even more natural to think
about word differences maybe the much
more of the story is told by what is in
the hypothesis but not in the premise or
the reverse alignment based features
that would key into an older idea from
an Li that it's kind of important to
figure out how the two the premise and
hypothesis relate to each other
negation of course I think it's
worthwhile having separate features that
would key into negation as well as other
lexical classes because all of this
stuff is really deeply affecting
entailment you know things like verbs of
saying and attitudes and modal's and
hedges and all that stuff a lot of stuff
that I think is relevant for sentiment
carries over here because of the way it
modulates claims that we make quantify
our relationships of course you'd want
to capture those they are not in word
net but definitely worth maybe even the
effort of hand coding them and then you
could also have named entity features
that's kind of like the James Dean Jimmy
Dean James Byron Dean situation and this
is not meant to be exhaustive rather
just to get you thinking about different
ways that you could key into lexical
information constructional information
and also world knowledge all that stuff
should be brought in given the way we
framed the nli problem questions about
that or comments or ideas all right nli
experiment again this is the pattern
that's repeating for all of this code
stuff it's kind of standard language for
thinking about running experiments in a
production i's way and I've provided a
bunch of code for that let me just walk
through it at a high level just to show
you how easy this could be so as usual
you point your repository to the data
here that's s nli home here just to
illustrate I have defined word overlap
Phi as my feature function as usual we
have these wrappers here it's fit
softmax so that you can as part of the
experiment pipeline do cross-validation
and fiddle with the parameters and do
other things that involves that are part
of model
setup slightly different from the
Stanford sentiment treebank we have
these reader objects so here I've set up
trained reader ten and the reason for
that is they have this extra argument
called sample percentage sent percentage
and I here I've set it at 0.1 I think
that's really important for development
because if you leave that off or say Sam
percentage equals none then your
experiments are going to be run on the
full five hundred and fifty K examples
and your progress will slow to a crawl
because every experiment might take
hours or days so what I would encourage
is at least one way that you would
develop on this data set is to do it on
small subsets which are randomly
selected and then once you feel like
your system has stabilized expand out to
a larger chunk of the problem so you set
up that trained reader and then it's
going to look a lot like the SST right
so you have the trained reader argument
your feature function word overlap Phi
and fits off max it's like a Swiss Army
knife you have a lot of other options
but those can be left off and that's
pretty much all it takes to run an
experiment and as before basic
experiment there is a dictionary that
more or less stores all the information
about your experiment for
reproducibility and error analysis and
so forth does that make sense that's the
basic framework very familiar I think
let me show you two other things that
you that I would encourage so first
hyper parameter selection on train
subsets so again so unlike SST where
it's small enough that you can kind of
do a lot of experiments in a pretty
manageable way when you move to the
level of F and a lie every experiment is
a major investment and again you just
won't make that much progress if you're
not thinking about how to do smaller
stuff that will inform the full picture
so I'm going to show you or give you
suggest to you two ways that you might
do that when it comes to hyper parameter
selection so first let me just set this
up this will be on Train subsets so you
point your data you know SML I home as
usual word overlap five will be my
feature function fits off mix with
cross-validation that's going to look at
a lot of different values of the
regularization strength C
both penalty types l1 and l2 so that's a
pretty big grid of Piper parameters you
have to fit a lot of models especially
with CV at 3 there so that's gonna have
to fit a lot of models and if again if
you do it on the full data set it will
just take too long so one approach you
might take is to set those hyper a
parameters based on a small subset of
the data here I've done it at 10% you
can see they get printed there so this
model chose C of 1 and penalty of l2 and
then having made that selection you
could play it forward right so here now
same feature function but now it's fit
softmax classifier with pre-selected
parameters where I just hard code in the
values that I selected from my earlier
experiment and then you go forward and
in that way you got some of the benefits
of exploring the hyper parameter space
without all the costs make sense any
questions or comments or concerns you
want to bring out because the dataset is
almost exactly balanced you get balanced
subsets out but I think you're raising
an interesting weakness of the approach
I just sketched which is that 10% how do
I know how representative is it is it of
the true full data set and in particular
the feature space that you form on that
tiny subset might be very different from
the one that you get from the full
training set and for example that might
deeply affect how much regularization
you want to do and I think that's a
weakness of the current approach that
makes sense so that's that's just just
to be like that's a compromise of that
one here's another method that you might
use that has not that weakness but maybe
others and this would be hyper parameter
selection with a few iterations so all
of these machine learning models they go
through a certain number of epochs of
training
and you know a single epoch might be
manageable but if it takes a thousand
for your model to converge that's where
you're incurring the real costs so
another approach you might take would be
to as I've done here fits off max with
cross-validation small inner where I
just find the parameter for the model
I'm fitting there it's max it are there
for logistic regression and set it to a
very small value like three or five and
then I do the full grid search that I
wanted to do before it's just that that
takes much less time even if I do it
over the whole data set as I'm doing
down here
because of the the iteration number is
so low and again you get a report down
here here it shows L 1 as the
regularization parameter not l2 and the
performance is slightly better and then
you apply that forward in the way that I
showed you before so the implicit
assumption you're making there is that
the future for training epochs is going
to be like the past that a setting that
was really bad early on is not gonna
somehow emerge as the hero of this story
later once bad Oh is bad and conversely
the ones that are good right out of the
gate are probably the ones that will be
good even if you run the model to
convergence I'm not offering you a
guarantee because I think no such
guarantee could be offered but rather
that this might be a good compromise
given a budget that you have on training
time or on compute resources and so
forth and you could mix and match these
because both of these things in the
grand scheme of things are very quick
compared to fitting a model on the
entire data set one more thing here and
then we might wrap up I just wanted to
show you how easy it is in the framework
tests to set up and run a hypothesis
only experiment and I think this is
pretty obvious there's the feature
function hypothesis only unigram Spy
takes in two trees t1 and t2 but then it
operates only on t2 it just throws away
t1 I used Fitz off max classifier with
pre-selected params
I ran the experiment and lo and behold
65 0.34 the mackerel f1 right that is
very different from a random baseline
which would be like 33 34 percent that
shows you how powerful this can be so if
your model is that 68 and you feel like
oh that's wonderful compared to random
well you should contextualize it in this
way and I hope that's not dispiriting
and I it's worth checking to see how
much information is in the premise
actually uh I'm gonna do that as a
follow-up oh yeah there it is compared
to random and actually here I just
wanted to show you just in case you
didn't know this that psych it has all
these great dummy classifier models that
allow you to fit models that just make
use of the like label distribution or
just guess at random and so here I just
did the diligent thing of actually using
one of those and sure enough yeah 33.4%
so the hypothesis only baseline is a
very strong baseline questions about
that it should we make the baseline for
doing all the exact same operations as
our model but only on the second tree or
should it what is the given the model
that you're developing what is the true
nature of the hypothesis only baseline
that's a judgment call because for
example if I picked word cross-product
features as my basic feature function
that's undefined if I'm looking only at
the hypothesis and so I have to say like
well the you know grams are pretty close
to being like my true feature function
but it's it's it's a tough thing to say
if you've despecialized to premise and
the hypothesis but if it's handed out
features I might just default to you
know grams seems pretty plausible and
then for the deep learning models I
think these questions are
more straightforward good I think rather
than diving into those let me leave this
for next time so next time we're gonna
look at sentence encoding models where
you get a separate representation for
premise and hypothesis and then we'll
look at chained ones which more or less
just put the two together into a single
typically an RNN of some kind and then
we'll look at attention mechanisms and
do some error analysis and if we get
through that as usual these that we'll
leave some time for you to just code on
homework four with the teaching team
available for you great